hello I'm Kyle Shepherd and this is
hidden brisson luck bible have asked me
to go up and down the UK exploring what
makes britain great
Clarkson May and Hammond are off sunning
it in Joburg and Dubai for the Grand
Tour we can't do that because we don't
really at the butcher who really needs
it when all the exotic you need is right
here at home in the UK so this episode
we've come to Wales to explore what
Snowdonia has to offer so just arrived
here and graduated the hotel so you go
to get himself checked in this was
pretty nice Kyle shampoo yeah it's quite
nice isn't the penile grid hotel has
been run by the same family flight over
70 years Edmund Hillary who's the first
blow to climb Everest stayed and trained
here before he will before he climbed
Everest games room like all of his TV is
slightly Nana's TV though straight as an
arrow that today though the hotels still
dead popular of people who want to climb
and explore the surrounding mountains
although a thing I've come with her on
Sunday year because I seem to be the
only one staying
I had a chat though Sal manager and he
said I should go check out the local
cafe feet seats checkout pcs oh yeah
I've just arrived at peat seats this is
where the hikers go to to get breakfast
before I let's go check it out then Pete
seats have bumped into Martin who was a
hiker he was also from Merseyside I
thought this was a bit odd because we
were in Wales but didn't say anything
but I did ask him about hiking so what
is walking hiking you call it a hiking a
friend of mine used as Mountain walking
I said to him one time said I hope you
enjoyed your hike today I said hi kid
you don't call it that
it's master dwarfism so anyway what
happened walk it in the hill don't look
like the mountain area no he do look
like you got a cinema actually no I
thing is you've got you look to be like
you've got quite a light frame and all
that looks actually very good for rock
climbing there's a guy called streaky
for example medical climber through the
tall thin guy yeah see the guy at
streaks no no no no it's just because
he's tall things you know what what
nickname would you give me and give you
a clue of what used to be called as a
kid and give us a clue that midgets lean
mitches lean [ __ ] how about that
that's worse I think you're quite thing
is well there aren't you you could be
known as the to stick listen you're not
getting me to take me clothes off that's
good quick so lean [ __ ] went off to
meet Tony and Caroline to hiking
instructors who had agreed to take me my
first ever high gear mountain hike
heightened multiple
yoga
hello Carolinas vo barking Sparky and so
if we're going up Sneed and I think we
might need to because if it starts
raining these will go dead tight on the
lakes Brian look I'm a more suit and
boot ready for the big climb right in
the scrub corner sparking this is how
you do it with the team so I was only
expecting like a 20-minute walk is it
just me of these getting in the way
they're just tired yeah come on a leash
kinky so as we reach the top I'm [ __ ]
freezing uh I can see why you're through
this it's really nice okay
oh okay yeah cuz I can see yeah just
okay cool three that's fantastic hey
although it didn't mix of atop of
Snowdon it was still amazing the views
are incredible it's bloody good exercise
plus it didn't die or anything which is
a bonus and so what better way to chill
out and celebrate then use the hotel
sauna and plunge pool let's go check out
sauna Sean
come on boy just affair is it too late
why hold
[Applause]
it's freezin not nothing it's safe to
say we won't be getting back in the lake
and me pants again but the solos ace
after I had two bats the hotel bar to
chat with the other guests the producers
told me they had one more thing cell for
me outside of town in an old quarry so
we added off again wasn't batteries
it turns out love Bible uh put me in its
zip world which and I'll know isn't a
place where they make zips so I'm Nathan
one of the instructors here at zip of
Asti the big zip line here starts about
50-100 feet above sea level it is just
under a mile long and the top speeds
reached on this have up to 120 miles per
hour cool yeah
London 20 call okay yeah
when it came to Wales is all down for
doing some proper Welsh stuff light but
another thought I'd be chucking myself
off a bloody quarry for the to work with
right great I'm gonna set to go
[Applause]
they were jumped up anything before car
yeah just yeah what's up what's up fair
[ __ ] let's say is a solid nine I'll
tell ya wish I don't sound up to this
[Music]
[Applause]
I was talking well daddy I wasn't really
all scared to be honest okay excuse me
it's been a great trip and proper NUCCA
divided that good time like I've really
gone with the crows ooh Snowdonia it's
been a blast I've got to say it's a
beautiful place I've met some great
people
I literally forever a quarry literally
and I've climbed over the highest
mountain England and Wales although yeah
technically thing gets to the top all
and although I definitely come back so
next time mates solo that's what can
awesome minor
you